[Music]
so i appreciate a good culture i
appreciate a good accent
you got the right accent you can get
away with a lot of [ __ ] you'll be in a
club and say something foul to a woman
an american accent
she might slap the [ __ ] out of you like
excuse me baby i don't mean to bother
you but you got a fat ass
i love to take you home [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out you [ __ ]
english accent that just roll off the
tongue different excuse me i don't mean
to bother you
but i really love to take you back to
motel [ __ ] you doggy stuff a little bit
you know i mean
[ __ ] where you from
oh my god say something else
ladies you're laughing some of the
fellas when i tried it on the way home
did you have a good time at the comedy
show tonight is it really
the next light because you give me a
little bit ahead just a little bit
i don't want much just want you to
polish me know if you know i'm like
i ain't even gonna lie i'll use that
[ __ ] to get some [ __ ] i walk up to a
woman and say anything
excuse me you know what time it is oh my
god the accent is beautiful where are
you from
i just make [ __ ] up mcdonald's england
have you ever heard of it
i live right over egg mcmuffin lane have
you ever had
oh my god girl you live my bag make
muffins
i tell you what accent is not sexy is
that east indian accent that's 7-eleven
[ __ ] that turban [ __ ]
that dot towel [ __ ] ladies trust me you
do not want that on top of you on a
saturday night
i'm going to give it to you i know you
wanted your dirty [ __ ] and i abandoned
i'm going to give you my pakasani beef
you [ __ ]
say my name say puma sanji pumasanji
[Applause]
but like i said i have ll snoop dmxjz
i'd have ll do the intro because he just
got that cool suave swagger
like ll seemed like he don't even need a
woman to be turned on he can stand in
front of the mirror chest neck and turn
himself off
like he'll be standing dj hit that track
for me
yo what's up what's up baby this is your
man ill cool j
oh ain't nothing like when you put
vanilla ice cream on your chest let it
melt down to your genitals
i got my man snoop dogg dmx and jay-z in
the building it's about to be real
sexual
real erotic baby
[Music]
[Applause]
having three hoes in some gangster [ __ ]
you know how a dog dope went against a
pimp we don't sweat [ __ ] cup
cause we know we can't be faded we just
sit back debated while getting our hair
braided
nate dog warren g dazz and corrupt we
gon rap till we die that's why we throw
them
things [ __ ] with my nizzle in the lbc
you know my name's snook dingo
double g yo it's your man dmx where's my
dogs out
where's my dogs
[Music]
don't get
[Music]
[Music]
him
[Applause]
[Applause]
think you got it locked on barbara i'm
taking the game father i'm throwing when
i hit
helen out when i switch i'm like i turn
up how much love when i'm pissed if you
haven't girl problems i feel bad for you
son i got 99 problems but a [ __ ] ain't
one
[ __ ] boy
national geographic because i like the
nature channel
like i want to go to africa one day
going to safari see the animals in their
natural habitat
but the difference between us and y'all
is we stay in the truck
white people y'all got some [ __ ] called
up close and personal
like it's just amazing too because
that's what black people we just know
certain [ __ ]
you know like white people that's why i
study all nvr i'm envious to y'all y'all
a race y'all do whatever the [ __ ]
you don't want to do y'all you know
y'all are free you're the only race of
people that could look at a wild lion
and go i can be friends with that
that's why y'all are always on when
animals attack you will never see black
people
or when animals attack you might see us
on when cops attacked but she would
never see us
on an animal's attack y'all would do
[ __ ] like tranquilize a lion and hold
that [ __ ] tail he wake up and
that'd be heavy [ __ ] to y'all y'all be
in the camera
[Music]
well my partner bob and i
we've been tracking this particular
beast for quite some time
her name is utulu she's six months old
we just shot her with five cc's of
textual coeur d'alene darts
when she gets up she's gonna be [ __ ]
pissed
oh my god bob do you feel your heart
pounding this is amazing
oh my god she's getting a plow oh she
molded me what an experience
the africans don't be out there [ __ ]
with the lions they ask them mr matumbu
why you don't play with the lion i'm not
[ __ ] with that [ __ ]
[ __ ] him and [ __ ] you that [ __ ] is not
in the brochure i'm not doing that [ __ ]
when my shift is over i want to go home
to my children mangulu mangala and
i can't do it [ __ ] with that when the
[ __ ] around you better come i will leave
you in the car
hi noah it's rules
ain't no african people here is it
are you african dog my bad i want to
piss you off and you [ __ ]
you know what's [ __ ] up african people
don't like black people
y'all know they treat us like [ __ ] they
talk down to us they think they're
better than us
and i don't understand cause we're from
the same tribe
kind of but they like white people
though they treat y'all like family
as soon as y'all come around they get
excited excuse me mr white man
thank you for bringing us here we love
you
yeah you're right mommy
[Applause]
as soon as they see us they get attitude
hey how you doing this [ __ ]
we don't like the black man in america
[ __ ] you don't work you don't do
[ __ ]
we don't like you you black [ __ ]
like oh you calling black [ __ ]
i'm brown you midnight who the [ __ ] are
you calling black
like [ __ ] if you stood up against a
building you'd look like an alley who
the [ __ ] are you going
the [ __ ] is unjust african men don't
understand why when they come to america
they have a hard time getting american
[ __ ]
you can't be that aggressive with
american women especially black women
you got to know how to talk you got to
come correct mohammed is in africa is
used to having a way they got 15 wives
and [ __ ]
and african women are very obedient they
tell they women what to do it's not even
the issue
[ __ ] when they come home you
i don't know why they do that
you you better you better clean this
[ __ ] from the floor i don't
maybe in the club stalking women out
here you can't even see them they be as
black as my jacket
you just see the yellow of their eyes
from a distance looking like congo in
the bush
as soon as you go by your drink they
jump out the shadows and scare the [ __ ]
at you [ __ ] what is your name
come here don't run from me
you're going to be my wife
what your hunters it's instagram
i went to belgium i was excited about
that
because i'm an action movie fanatic and
i noticed where jean-claude van damme is
from
and ironically enough i watched that
movie on the plane ride over expendables
too
he plays the bad guy in the movie he has
a fight scene with sylvester stallone at
the end of the movie
i thought stallone schwarzenegger was
hard to understand
here's a moment just before the fight
van damme says to stallone
don't try to challenge me
it took me 45 minutes
to figure out that [ __ ] was
trying to say challenge
don't try to challenge me i said what
the [ __ ] is a challenge
sound like a gay black male hairdresser
oh my god girl your hair's nice who did
you said chillands
like i can't even believe salona
schwarzenegger's still making action
movies
this morning's 187 years old
and i'm a huge sly fan i love in rocky
movies i'm gonna come out with rocky 48
i'll be right there
my favorite rocky movie was rocky 3 when
his trainer died not because his trainer
died just
hearing stallone cried for the first
time was magical remember that scene in
rocky 3 when he loses the club lagging
the first time
he goes back into the locker room and
mickey's laying on that cot he's got
that blanket over his chest he's on his
last breath he's like
sorry so
stallone starts crying me
[Music]
to do
[Applause]
you ever noticed in the rocky movies
whenever he starts out normal you can
understand him
but the more emotion we get he just
[ __ ] lose you like remember that
scene in rocky 3 when he stand on the
beach and he's all stressed and
disheveled
and adrian's like rocky what's wrong
he's like
hey you know i don't want it no more
what are you talking about and when i
first got in the ring
i didn't care what happened to me i
didn't care when i was you
as a kid i want to lose what i got will
you
[Applause]
so we have to address it uh bill cosby
y'all think he did it
see listen if you like me i'm 39 years
old if you're my age and older you don't
want to believe it because you know
he you grew up with him that's that's
our father that's that's cliff huxtable
but i think we put too much emphasis on
celebrity people act like because you
iconic and talented
and famous and rich you're exempt from
being [ __ ] up and doing crazy [ __ ]
what makes them any different from
regular people the only thing that makes
them different is they got fame power
money that don't mean they can't be
you know the ability to do [ __ ] up
[ __ ] does that mean michael jackson was
a pedophile
i don't know i'm just saying talented
people can be [ __ ] up too
i just don't want to believe this [ __ ]
because in my mind i'm thinking what the
[ __ ]
does bill cosby rape sound like
[Applause]
[ __ ]
you are going to give me the bootleg
[Applause]
she's trying to fight him all the [ __ ]
no bill no [ __ ] double double double d
i just i don't want to believe it [ __ ]
it's scariest
it's hard for blacks to make it in
hollywood too man cause the rules are
different
you know hollywood you gotta you gotta
be humble no matter what color you are
but if you're black
you really gotta be [ __ ] humble you
know because sometimes it don't matter
how good you i remember i had lunch with
chris rock one time
he gave me the best advice he was like
look man all i can tell you is one
keep writing and two try not to piss
these white folks off
cause that [ __ ] is true it don't matter
how good you are if you're angry
if you're the angry black man they don't
[ __ ] with you case in point paul mooney
this motherfucker's a legend
everybody y'all know paul mooney this
[ __ ] wrote for richard pryor eddie
murphy
you a bad [ __ ] when you writing
for other bad [ __ ]
the problem with paul is paul will tell
you he's a bad [ __ ]
he'll shoot himself in the foot i
remember one time i tried to get him to
do a job
for mad tv i wanted him to be a writer i
said yo we already a great show
but paul he'll take us to the next level
paul will go into the [ __ ] meeting
and shoot himself in the foot as soon as
he walked in the producers was like paul
um aries recommends you highly he thinks
you're great
let me ask you are you familiar with our
show paul went right into it i've seen
your show
all of you [ __ ] have stolen my
material you've all stolen from me i've
seen it
it doesn't matter no homie homie listen
listen in living color
saturday live you all have stolen my
[ __ ] first you stole [ __ ]
then you stole my material
and in case you didn't know i invented
comedy [ __ ] i invented it
and then later on i'll see paul and go
paul how did it work homie they're not
gonna hire me i'm too real i'm too real
they're scared of me homie i'm too real
trust me they love [ __ ] at grin when
you grin you win
all the [ __ ] are grinned gwen
look at wayne brady they love that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] grins
that [ __ ] he has a hairdo from the 50s
he wears a perm
he's a throwback [ __ ] they love him
they love him homie it's true
white folks will tell you why can't you
be more like wayne we love
wayne they love grinning [ __ ] what
about that other [ __ ] that played
basketball for the lakers the [ __ ] he
owns businesses the [ __ ] with aids
magic johnson
they love that greater [ __ ] that [ __ ]
grinned his way through aids [ __ ] it's
true
have you ever seen that nigga's grin
it's from temple to temple
it's huge that [ __ ] looks like the cat
from alice in wonderland
they love that [ __ ]
here's the thing if you're not grinning
they'll talk about you it scares white
folks it scares them
i remember one time i was on a lot and
they said good morning paul
and i didn't grin i just nodded my head
they talk about you
why is that [ __ ] not dreading
that [ __ ] doesn't he know where he is
that [ __ ] should be critic
and if you grin too fast you scare white
folks i said good morning to a white
woman
i grinned real fast that [ __ ] was
scared i said good morning she said
that [ __ ] took off winning [ __ ] it's
true
[Applause]
is that [ __ ] gay
[Applause]
like everybody in this room individually
sexually
has something that you are into that is
downright
filthy uh disgusting
no one knows how nasty this is but you
and the lord
like if anybody else knew what the [ __ ]
you was into you would have to leave
the country i'm gonna tell you what my
thing is
i am an aggressive snatch sniffer uh
i love to smell a woman snatch and i'm
not talking delicate like a wine cork
like
huh no i get into the muzzle
i will wear a woman's [ __ ] on my face
like a surgical mask
and inhale to my rib cage show
have me making the cosby face
like i like a woman's [ __ ] to have a
little mugginess to it
is that a badass no no like a muggy like
an early morning
the sun's just coming up you could smell
the moisture off the grass from the
sprinkler system
the coffee's percolating the bacon set
like the day is beginning like
oh good morning
you're saying it's a straight man it's
kind of hard for me to wrap my mind
around that concept
cause i am a fan of [ __ ] like i know
all straight men love [ __ ] but i have a
sickness for
oh dear
[ __ ] is the greatest most natural
single sense
like let's be honest there's only four
things in life that feel really good
only four [ __ ] eating getting high
and scratching an inside acid
oh [ __ ] y'all don't judge me don't act
like i'm the only [ __ ] that's
ever felt pleasure
from scratching an inside acid you know
it feels good because whenever you ever
done it and not closed your eyes
and you hum a little bit um
who the [ __ ] scratches the inside assets
with their eyes wide open
it's one of the best feelings in life
but i'm saying [ __ ] oh my god ladies
you understand how magical that
contraption is between your legs
men start wars over [ __ ] we're at war
right now in the middle east ain't got
[ __ ] to do
with terrorism it's about oil and oil is
money
and if you got some money you just [ __ ]
it's about [ __ ]
ladies you don't give yourselves enough
credit next time you get out the shower
and your butt naked and wet
take a second look at yourself in the
mirror and high-five your [ __ ]
bow salute yourself you're worth it
i wish i could randomly go around high
five [ __ ] i wish i could do it
excuse me miss you know what time it is
3 30. thank you [ __ ]
even the fact that i mentioned the word
[ __ ] i look in the room and i see some
of you ladies looking at me drawing back
like uh stop it this is for you
i'm trying to tell you we don't
celebrate women's bodies enough ladies
y'all need to stop getting caught up in
some of these women's magazines
and paying attention to some of these
anorexic ass actresses [ __ ] with your
head trying to define for you
what beauty is supposed to be because i
got news for you
as men we don't give a [ __ ]
about what you give a [ __ ] about the
minute you get butt-necked you've won
you got us
you think we really give a [ __ ] about
some love handles our standards are not
that high
we [ __ ] from the back you got love
handles we're like children we act like
we driving a car
honk on your butt cheek [ __ ] baby move
we don't give a [ __ ]
i love [ __ ] god damn it oh i'll be glad
when they put that [ __ ] in the
toothpaste jesus christ
i'll be at cvs for 47 tubes of [ __ ]
pace
i brush my teeth four times a day i
wouldn't even wrench just suck it dry
it's a beautiful word [ __ ] isn't it
like if a woman came up to me and said
sir
eat my [ __ ]
absolutely
if a woman said eat my vagina mmm
sound too much like vegetables
i don't know man it's crazy too much you
know i respect the art
like i get upset when i hear about these
actors that get paid 20 million dollars
a movie
to act and the key word is act but they
paid us to do this who never could
[ __ ] act how do you pay stallone and
schwarzenegger
20 million dollars a movie pay that to
the dudes who deserve it like pacino
dinero denzel
morgan this has a [ __ ] actress man
because to this day one of my favorite
movies of all time
his heat with pacino and dinero anybody
that's ever seen the movie knows what
i'm talking about
it's like they took the two greatest
actors of all time and put them in a
scene together if you've never seen the
movie go rent it smoke a joint
it's great you got that scene where they
meet for the first time and pacino's
sitting there with deniro
he's bringing [ __ ] down to him he's like
you sir her a bad guy
i am the police it's my job to stop guys
like you
murderers rapers killers it's what i do
there may come a time when i pass cross
i'm gonna have to take you down i won't
like it but i'll do it keeps me hot
on my toes where i gotta be
de niro comes back you know there's a
flip side to that coin
good friend of mine jimmy once told me
never get attached to anything that you
cannot walk out on in 15 seconds flat if
you spot the heat
coming around the corner and i also like
guys like you that like guys like me
because you keep me hot
on my toes but i gotta beg
and you're right i patch they may cross
i'm gonna have to take you down
i won't like it but i will not hesitate
great scene now hold up picture the same
scene with stallone and schwarzenegger
you ain't gonna be able to understand
[ __ ] stallone
[Music]
without do it wow
even deaf people like what do you think
what do you think
[Applause]
can you imagine him asking this woman
for head maria come on give me heckle
down
don't come up for air please to your
ears
fellas you want to freak your woman out
during sex make that noise so the [ __ ]
up
you'll be hitting him from the back
the [ __ ] is wrong with you don't worry
about what's great enough here
put your head down ladies it'll work for
you too you don't want to get your man
head do that it'll stop immediately
as soon as you get down there ow [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
what you making keys or something
no you ain't gonna put a handicap sign
on my balls i'm good to go
that's a good noise to make if you want
privacy in a public bathroom you will
clear that [ __ ] right out
as soon as you get in there
sir you all right get out get away it's
going to be an explosion
gentle the chopper now i don't know why
he says that he says that in every move
can't do the chopper now
i like to make that noise on a crowded
elevator especially if i got the fart
people just assume there's something
wrong with me as soon as i rip one oh my
god what was that
smell if it's nice to smell it
give to the chopper get down
oh my god he's [ __ ] he didn't even
have a helmet on
you know what's funny some of y'all
laughing but some of y'all gonna go home
and [ __ ] tonight
and when you come you're gonna do that
it's gonna be hilarious like girl i'll
let you
out i'm finished get me a paper towel
come here
wipe it down get to the chopper now
don't drink and drive because if you get
pulled over that's exactly how you sound
sir have you been drinking
i had the jager and patron to the
chopper now
uh we're gonna need backup we're gonna
need backup and apparently we need a
chopper i don't know why but
actually i actually met arnold
schwarzenegger man
true story i was doing a show in san
jose california
and it's like a five and a half hour
drive outside of l.a and i stopped at a
chevron
and this [ __ ] was on pump number
seven filling up his h2
now i don't really get starstruck like
if this had been van damme or cigar i'd
have been like
whatever this is [ __ ] terminator this
is conan like i grew up on this
[ __ ]
and i saw him and i was so excited i was
like yo arnold man i love you [ __ ]
he ain't even look at me he was just
like yeah how are you
and i called my boy and i said [ __ ] you
ain't gonna believe it arnold
schwarzenegger he's on pump number seven
filling up he's like [ __ ] you lying i
said i swear to god he was like arnold
schwarzenegger i said [ __ ]
and arnold heard me and i swear he went
just like this
it's like his marco polo he understood
it was like a mating call he knew
some of the fellas might remember where
i got that remember the scene and
predator when he got ready to fight the
alien and he covered himself with mud he
was like i'm here
killing me come on do it
[ __ ] funny man
so i'm saying fellas can't always be
honest with your woman in bed sometimes
you'll be [ __ ] your girl and you for
yourself give me a comment you announce
that [ __ ]
don't announce it just do it cause when
you announce it that's when it backfire
on you
babe i'm about to
i'm about to come cause you know what
she gonna say
don't come yet
ladies do you know how hard it is
for a man to stop an oncoming nut
it take every muscle in a [ __ ] body
to seize up at once
we got to pull from my toes all the way
up
from the side we look like a question
mark
a man will go in the cardiac arrest
behind that [ __ ]
all of a sudden sex turn into a crime
scene detectives show up
hey what do we got dude tried to stop a
nut
and black people we got too much stress
[ __ ] police is out of control
ain't they
police is out here killing [ __ ] like
we dears
i'm surprised they ain't taking pictures
with us posing that's holding us by ears
it's [ __ ] scary man hey let's get so
bad even white people starting not to
like police
but y'all don't i don't respond the way
we respond it's different emotions
white people when the cops pull you all
over y'all get mad cause you can't
believe they had the audacity
to pull you over so y'all hear that
noise
see them like [ __ ] like [ __ ] cops
the [ __ ] does he want as soon as he gets
to my window i'm going to give him a
piece of my mind
black people we don't get angry we get
uncomfortable we get the hot booty rim
hole
you know what the hot booty rim hole is
that's a feeling you get when you think
you got the fart but you realize you got
the [ __ ]
cause the rim of your booty hole heat up
as soon as we hear that noise
whip [ __ ] oh
i gotta get a toilet seat put in my car
and i'm not just here to tell jokes i
actually want to give back i want to
help white people
i want to be like y'all's black dr phil
because comics we don't do much when we
on the road we stay in hotel room and
watch tv
and i'm flipping through the channels
and i'm watching these some of these
programs like oprah and phil
and i'm noticing some of y'all's kids is
out of [ __ ] control
i really want to ask white people why
don't y'all beat y'all kids
beat them what they [ __ ] ass
y'all give your kids
all kind of timeouts and special places
what the [ __ ] is a special place
to a black child that's a coma what is a
special place
black kids don't know [ __ ] about timeout
we know about getting knocked the [ __ ]
out that's it
my mother used to slap the [ __ ] out of
me in public and i would look at people
for help
like shut up
white people felt my pain oh my god she
just struck her a child
black people see black kids get hit we
like hey
get your [ __ ] together
you know what i found out growing up
totally shocked me white kids are just
as shocked to find out black kids don't
talk back to their parents
because we are when we hear them talk
back to theirs because i used to have a
little buddy would come over my house on
the weekends a little nate
we'd be in my room playing video games
my mother used to come in the room on us
and cuss me out for no reason
just scare the [ __ ] out of both of us
right we be in the room playing mario
brothers she come kick open the door
like swat
we're on level four she just harris how
many times that i told you to clean this
[ __ ] room cut that goddamn game
off and clean this room i come back this
[ __ ] roommate clean i'ma take
the nintendo chord
wrap it around your neck and stick it in
your ass [ __ ] i ain't playing with you
this ain't no threat
it's a promise try me [ __ ] try
me
[Applause]
my white friend would turn to me
offended like dude what the [ __ ]
she can't do that man this is your space
it's your area
she's violating your right to privacy
you should say something you want me to
go say something
i'd be so scared i started talking to
him like a slave from roots like
he was gonna get me's and travis
i like you nate i really do but my
parents is good black folk that gives me
food that gives me sleeps
now you get away from around here with
that foolishness get from here
[Applause]
my mother smacked the [ __ ] out the white
boy he turned into me wade
in the water
it's crucial man
i was in popeye's chicken around the
playoffs for basketball
and i'm arguing with this [ __ ]
about my order he didn't understand me i
didn't understand him
[ __ ] was terrible i was like dawg let me
get a two-piece chicken dinner he tried
to repeat the [ __ ] back to me
you wanted to be icky
do you want this spicy or demaio i said
what it said de spicy or demaio
i said what [ __ ] you know put
mayonnaise on chicken why would i put
mayonnaise
on chicken i'm a hot sauce [ __ ] my
daddy was a hot sauce
he said no demaio for the flavor i said
what the [ __ ] is flavor
he kept looking at the menu like it was
family feud and the answer was going to
pop up on the board
i'm going to tell you the dewy chicken
with these baizio de mayo better
let me get a two-piece chicken spicy
he said you want it busy i said yes
[ __ ] i'm busy
i don't have time for this [ __ ] i'm
trying to catch the game
kobe's on [ __ ] come on
you say no it busy i said what the [ __ ]
is he pissing
him and the cream cheese i said a
biscuit he said see see if he's going to
deal with you with the doobie jiggy we
just bite your map
[Applause]
let me get a two-piece chicken spicy
with a biscuit
he said now you'll have to pickle your
sides
i said i'm not playing with my penis and
pop eyes i'm not doing that why would i
pull my dick out and jack off near the
crunchy i'm not doing it
he said no you get through side order i
said what kind of side you got
he said well how about they well how
about they
it was we have though but we have a day
we're having the yakironi and yes
what happened to yash i said [ __ ] it let
me go with the ash potato
she wants something to drink i said what
do you have to drink
well how about they
well how about the sodas and the uses
i said i don't want no soda but i'm
curious about your uses
the [ __ ] is used what happened the apple
use
i didn't use grapefruit you listen the
point is we have to demand more from our
illegals
i'm airy spears and i approve this
message we have to demand more it's
unacceptable
i get people to come to me after my
shows and have me nickel bags blunts
joints
i had a white boy one time give me some
edible weed i wish somebody would have
told me that edible weed is 50 times
more potent
than the [ __ ] you smoke and when white
boys give you weed they come with
warning labels you gotta listen to [ __ ]
they say
i had a white dude give me five
miniature reese's pieces of size cups
edible weed
i was like dawg is this [ __ ] even strong
this white boy looked me dead in my face
it was like dude
trust me you do that you're going to see
tomorrow today
god damn i ate all five in the
[ __ ]
i was driving home i was like man this
ain't [ __ ] cut too i'm in my house butt
naked
making carpet angels [ __ ]
my nuts had eight hours of rug burn that
[ __ ] was serious
funny thing is you don't even realize
how racist america is until after you
leave
you know like i did a show not too long
ago in edmonton canada
there was no racist vibe in edmonton
well first of all ain't no [ __ ] out
there so anybody be mad at
but i must have walked around that
[ __ ] for four days looking for a
black person
finally i saw one i ain't even know the
[ __ ] i just ran up to him and
hugged him like [ __ ] where you been
we need to stick together he was
offended he was like dude get your hands
off of me bro
it's like totally absurd i was like [ __ ]
they got him
it was too late i couldn't save him
i had white kids looking at me like i
was an exotic animal
it was like mom look at him he's so
chocolatey
i want one he kept trying to pour milk
on me i was like ain't gonna change
colors
[ __ ] off me
and i see some of the white people
getting uncomfortable don't get
uncomfortable
i love white people man y'all my people
too it's just certain [ __ ] i can't do
with you
like go drinking every time i do a show
in front of white people after the show
you always want to hang out and buy me a
drink i can't drink with y'all
it's not that i don't want to it's just
i can't hang you [ __ ] are the
undisputed champs
drinking y'all drink till y'all fall the
[ __ ] out
and i know when y'all get good and drunk
cause that's that noise you'll make
[Applause]
don't do that that's scare black folk
there's a lot of bad history behind that
noise
black people we hit whoa we started
looking out for pickup trucks where the
[ __ ] they at
see this one like [ __ ] with earl he
played too much
i'm serious a party ain't a party to
y'all to the [ __ ] cops show up
and black people y'all know we see the
police party over
white people y'all have a freedom we
just don't have y'all see the police
y'all get braver
dude what's your [ __ ] badge number
one your name no don't [ __ ] touch me
what if i [ __ ] touch you
no you shut the [ __ ] up and move along
ares why are you crying relax
do you know who my dad is i'll sue i
swear to god get the [ __ ] on
black people we'd be in the back doing
sign language